what should we know about our
understanding of black holes in the
formation is that an important thing to
understand in the formation of a galaxy
like uh so all the orbiting all the
spiraling that's going on how important
is that to understand all of the above
that's what makes astronomy really hard
but also really interesting right no
days like another because we always find
something new
um I want to come back to the the idea
of the Proto Galaxy because we've
actually matches or you know relates to
to the black hole formation so most
large gal well pretty much all large
Galaxies have a supermassive black hole
in the center and we don't actually know
don't we don't really know where they
come from again we know that they are
there but how how do we get there so if
we go back to the to the early Universe
right we had a
a little Galaxy that just sort of you
know I don't know had some small number
of stars it was the first
gravitationally bound structure that
that was held together by dark matter
because Dark Matter actually kind of
structured up you know first before the
Luminous matter could because that's
what Dark Matter kind of does and it it
started to hold
um gas and then Stars sort of together
in these first very shallow
um what we call potential well so these
gravitationally bound systems
and then the Milky Way Grew From
absorbing neighboring smaller even
smaller systems and somewhere in that
process
there must have been a seed for one of
these supermassive black holes and I'm
I'm not actually sure that it's clear
right now kind of what was there first
the Supermassive Black Hole uh or the
Galaxy so lots of people are trying to
study that and of course the black hole
wasn't as massive back then as it is
these days
um but it's that's a it's a big area of
research and the new James Webb the jwc
the telescope the infrared telescope in
space is um is working on the many
people are working on that
to to figure out exactly what what
happened and there are some some
surprising results
um that we really don't understand right
now so so to solve the uh the chicken or
the egg problem of uh do you need a
supermassive black hole to form a Galaxy
or does the Galaxy naturally create the
supermassive black yeah yeah I mean
that's
we can't answer that because there are
lots of little dwarf galaxies out there
you know the Milky Way remains
surrounded by many
um dozens of of small dwarf galaxies I
have studied a bunch of them and to the
extent that we can tell they do not
contain black holes
so there certainly were gravitationally
bound structures so either you can call
them proto-galaxies or dwarf galaxies or
first galaxies they were definitely
there
but there must have been bigger things
like the Proto Milky Way where something
was different right what made them more
massive so that you know they would
gravitationally attract these smaller
systems to to integrate them
so we'll have to see how do we look into
that the into the the Dynamics of the
formation the evolution of the portal
galaxies is it possible that they shine
I mean what what are the
set of data that we can possibly look at
so we've got gravitational ways
which is really insane that we can even
detect this
um there's the light
what else can we uh so that that would
fall into the category of observational
cosmology and the the jwst is is the
prime telescope right now to and it
promises big big steps forward this is
in its early days because it's only been
online like a year or so
um but that collects the infrared light
from the farthest
like literally Proto Galaxy's earliest
galaxies that light has traveled some 13
billion years to us and they are
observing these faint little blobs
um and folks are trying to you know
again study the early the onset of these
early supermassive black holes how they
shape Galaxy so they're they're seeing
that they are they were there you know
surrounded by already bigger galaxies
ideally I'd like for for my colleagues
to push a little bit further hopefully
that will eventually happen in terms of
looking towards older and older ones
yeah yeah more and more sort of
primitive in terms of the structure but
of course as you can imagine if you make
your system smaller and smaller it
becomes dimmer dimmer and it's further
and further that way so we're reaching
the end of the line from a technical
perspective pretty quickly but it's
different dimmer means older and older
um yes in a sense because it all started
really small
the smaller smaller which correlates to
older in that phase of the universe it
would otherwise it it doesn't